every morning that that i drop my kids  off at school i always say the same  thing be bold be brave be beautiful and  be kind say to him every day you know we  failed man like we failed we failed this  earth and we failed these kids and  there's every generation feels like  things are spiraling out of control  things move faster and faster and faster  my hope is that somehow  through art  through  connectivity and through the  universality that comes with how  connected we are now  that somehow  kindness can spread and the quadranting  off the isolation that is like gripping  all of us right now  is delivered into the zeitgeist and i  know this is very weird but like as  uncool  it's not cool to just be staring at your  phone all day you got to go out and  connect you got to go out and seek  relationships and find empathy  you